michael shannon reprises his role as zod
i will find him as a baby and
kill him i will kill that baby
what up reject nation we got ourselves
some big flash plot details revealed from
the test screenings speed on over to that
like button if you haven't done so already
john major fan of the flash just read every
comic that's ever existed so yeah we found a
thread that has been posted everywhere there's one
thread and we're going to react to it in real time
see what's in here spoiler warning i
think i imagine there's spoilers in here
this only stands to reason judge
the movie entirely based off of this
and then hold it against the movie
when things are different whether it be
there's a 100 a tease for reverse flash
when barry's mom is killed a yellow
figure smiles at barry and lunges at him barry
escapes before the yellow figure can get to him
no actor or voice it's pretty hard to make out
the figure uh because it's just standing in the
dark and you can only see his yellow arm and red
eyes oh yeah look out at least based off of the
way this first salon sounds is that there's not
gonna be a reverse flash character in the movie
but at least a setup or tease for him so it's
not exactly directly pulling everything from
flashpoint because reverse flash is arguably the
most personal villain for barry in a lot of ways
especially because he's gonna kill barry's mom i
guess saving him for a sequel but setting him up
now is is a good idea the emotional parts are
good oh great good to hear ezra has amazing
chemistry with the woman who plays barry's
mom and i heard people started crying when
barry realized he couldn't save her thousand times
better than the one in the cw who is playing ezra
miller's mom the woman he choked that's what that
looks like look if you stay quiet you could be in
the movie black flash is not really the villain
of the film it is future flash wearing a black
flash suit which won't confuse anyone they kind of
merged the two characters it's essentially future
flash just wearing black flash's suit there are
three berries in the film and the berry we see in
the trailers long hair gets brutally killed by
evil berry that's a reveal okay so black flash
is kind of like a death representation of the
speedsters if i'm not mistaken future flash was
sort of actually a semi-inspired i believe the
character was savitar did i remember that sabotage
from the flash series in season three future flash
is like a mournful flash a little bit corrupted
a little bit more villainous i've only seen the
first five seasons of the flash but i believe that
was season three if i'm not mistaken the future
flash is actually just the second berry long hair
but from the future his motivation is that when
the dcu berry came to his universe he ruined
everything and destroyed his world damn he has
gotten obsessed into saving his world and keeps
trying to reverse time from it getting destroyed
but it failed so he decided to go after the person
who caused this our barry interesting there are
plot points that seem sort of pulled from that
exact i mean it's in the comic so i suppose but
i'm like this is also like the tv series in a
lot of ways it says next feature flash spent 10
years trying to reverse time and figure out a way
to stop zod from destroying the world zod zod's
instincts do this why not barry was about to
go back in time but someone future barry
tried to kill him and accidentally knocked
him out of the speed force into an alternate
universe which is michael keaton's world okay
that's okay so you can just trip and fall anywhere
in the universe so is barry trying to go back to
save his mom or is he trying to go back because
he knows of the future which is the snyder verse
dark side thingy you know what i'm talking about
yeah is he trying to prevent that and then he goes
back or is he going back to try to save his mom
and then he winds up here is this from the the the
climax of jl you're looking at me trying to save
his mom if that's the prologue of the movie but
michael keaton's batman is still active and is
as unhinged now that alfred is dead babbitt 89
band returns are canon the movie addresses at
this batman kills batman forever and batman
and robin have been reckoned away yeah figures
sasha calallas super girl is car oh cara zorro
she's not the daughter of superman she is the
cousin even though they cast someone who looks
exactly like the daughter of superman she was the
one to survive krypton's destruction earthquake
instead of cal yeah okay but was captured by the
government upon land earth entire life locked away
in a military facility like flashpoint yeah except
gender swapped barry one our barry got stuck in
keenan's world and finds barry two who also has
flash powers and they both get keaton batman
and supergirl to fight a threat zod they lose
and barry wanted to try to reverse time to
save the universe but it fails our barry
gives up but barry two dozen that's when
future flash future barry two i wonder what it
was like reading the script because i know in a
visual medium it's really easy to keep up with but
it's like a script format you're like wait what uh
revealing he tried to repeat time multiple times
but it failed so instead of repeating time to stop
this incident he enters the speed force to try
and kill the person who causes in the first place
barry what oh wow so all this comes from barry
one hour barry ezra miller the ezra miller we know
and love he's just kind of debated by others
oscar fan favorite cheer moment ezra miller
that's the one who caused all this it's because
of that cheer worthy vote zod successfully
wait what are we still in act one what is going on
here it seems how is this layered are we reading
this backwards zod successfully kills kaden's
batman and supergirl supergirl gets her neck
snapped what the hell it's actually performed
brutal worse than when superman snapped zodz
that's what i want from this movie how
much worse can they get zod and fowler
my favorite character fiora
are alive in the new timeline
of steel yes i remember her zod killed
cavill superman as a baby killing super baby
is 100 true that's my favorite thing i've
read so far it works and we didn't do it
for hitler we did it for superman that
is going to piss some people off so much
now what a way to prevent superman from coming
into existence by killing the super baby michael
shannon reprises his role as zod i will find
him as a baby and kill him i will kill that baby
i want that line exactly future flash and flash
have a massive race because future flash wants to
kill him barry doesn't want to die that's good uh
when they do that they travel into the multiverse
we see a shitload of different universes
pattinson's batman universe linda carter wonder
woman adam west batman grant gustin's flash more
ezra's miller pattinson's batman that will fit
it's the right choice what i mean we're just going
to the worlds but do we see like cameos or just
the worlds i feel like yeah flash will just run
through a frame and then bruce will turn around
really quick and and then he'll make a joke about
hating it when people disappear really fast who
was that the answer is justice hopefully by the
end of the movie we'll see this is looking bleak
superman's existence is left somewhat ambiguous
schrodinger's what do you mean he's a dead baby
the best dead baby joke in the dceu any film and
tv show including peacemaker released between man
of steel and chasm 2 are said in the old timeline
shasm 2 is set in the old timeline everything
after the flash is set in the new timeline green
lantern zatanna batgirl i'm trying to understand
this so afterwards a new timeline is going
to be set up right that's what we all figured
would be the main timeline a new one go this is
the correct god what audience we know what we're
doing we know what we're doing unless you prove
otherwise let's see what like you will change
it again yeah we'll find a new multiverse reset
button you'll see we'll get it one of these days
iris is only a cameo in this movie and she
only appears at the end when barry's father
is released from prison well he gets really
yeah good good old uh wrap up to that story
there barry really made something of
himself wb's plan is to use keaton as
a temporary replacement for to see you batman
after i want to read the crosstalk part after
crisis which they are leading up to they now
say that they all know that pattinson will be
involved in crisis are they doing a crisis
on infinite earths that's the implication
yeah i mean they were going to at some point
sometimes when you just want to react on camera
maybe i should have gotten some notes before
doing this nothing of whether he will join the
dcu full-time afterwards wait a minute why why
are they doing a crisis on infinite earth so
soon you're already hopping a flashback that's the
point of the dc eu that's their theme is just what
we'll do let's get to the you know what's great
about marvel those culmination movies what if
every movie was just a culmination movie without
the five movies in between crisis on infinite
earth so you guys might have heard of secret wars
that that's being teased to possibly come up it's
just like multiverse and madness is coming out
and then you got flashboy coming out and then so
secret wars is like multiversal wars battles going
on that will result in a specific timeline christ
on infinite earth which was already done on the
crossover which featured ezra miller by the way
is now happening here then pattinson i
don't feel like just leave pattinson alone
batman is a good stand-alone franchise don't let
him do it don't haven't seen say no the answer is
justice the answer is justin oh batfleck here we
go batfleck doesn't die but isn't part of the new
timeline he's just stranded on it oh cool island
in this in the conte maybe he'll finally get his
batman movie ben affleck lives on it'll make a
weird fracture where now batfleck is the solo
universe not related batman and somehow battens
and gets folded into the garishness of whatever
the dcu becomes the movie is canon to the snyder
cut hey with iris west remembering that barry
allen saved her and barry and ben affleck's batman
talking about how barry has time traveled before
to save the day those references are kept vague
enough that people who didn't watch the snyder
cut won't really be confused i had that guess that
he would have gotten some inspiration from talking
with batman about how he time traveled that
one time isn't that a greekish so the movie
ends with the creation of a new dce with keenan's
batman and and cod how do you say your last name
batman is rebooted into a new version that never
killed we're gonna wipe away his damn sins and
his villains are still alive quick montage
of him bonking people with padded instruments
and all the same scenes i fighters here the
snyder verge becomes a parallel universe branch
timeline bath flight does not die his last scene
sets up his return on christ on infinite earth's
movie that wb is developing okay just won't let
him go all right let's go to the they got some
big credits post cred john take it away hey
mig credit says that flash will tell aquaman
that he wonders if a superman exists here too
and aquaman looks at him confused because there
ain't a superman there's not a super nah it then
proceeds to show supergirl smiling at bear and he
smiles back and shows him looking over what's next
to her his face is full of shock and the movie
ends maybe a cave will not but i don't know his
wp going let's wait to see if they like this or
not we'll bring that reverse back yeah it's still
possible even though we killed him just now as a
baby well no i mean it sounds like the superman
killed in their universe was a difference it
was different superman and it sounds like snyder
versus especially with affleck's alive based off
what i just pre-read off this post credits that it
also follows that affleck will can then continue
and i heard something like a couple days ago
about ben affleck going to see the nightmare of uh
snyder verse world i don't know how to talk
about these things we live in a society yeah yeah
affleck tease post credits come find us barry
affleck crisis teas oh so it's like a flipper
and it'll be those things and the answers is the
truth it's different catholic is now saying find
this berry well dude i mean look i have no opinion
on this other than like this sounds wild sounds
strange and bizarre i think that at least
they're not erasing the snyder verse from
what it sounds like it actually sounds like
they're they're keeping a separate timeline
in case they're like we need to go back to
that that seems like the smartest aspect of
this whole thing is that they are embrace i feel
like if you're going to open a multiverse then
you should absolutely have that avenue open
and that is is smart of them to do they don't
have to make a bunch more jl movies but hey if
it's profitable they can but i'm confused when
it says that zod kills supergirl and keaton's
batman i'm like i thought keaton's batman wasn't
wasn't back girl bad girl yeah that's a
prequel or uh he gets knocked into the
multiverse at a different point in time too
well guys this news is nuts what do you think
are you excited i know i am i was born excited
ezra miller should be held accountable leave
it off on that now how about that for an indian
set up for a casting change yet i'm still
excited for this movie to see what this turns
into and i'm happy that it's at least getting well
received thanks for being here i'll catch you guys